[Musica]
bella a tutti ragazzi mica come senti il
beat
non so niente di questo gioco aspetta
porca cosa devo fare qui cosa come si
gioca
non ho fatto niente aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta
ripartiamo massei storto tu ma allora
scusa allora vedi che già così molto
bene ma questa cosa devo fare che gioco
è balene a parte la musica che è
bellissima io sono su una sedia da
gaming e stiamo andando da qualche parte
non ho capito dove pro è fatto benissimo
sto gioco e come è bello che c'è una
grafica pazzesca ma è una gara devo
batterli io devo battere questi qua in
qualche modo non so come ma non puoi
abbassare un però la musica è abbastanza
alta no non si può
gianpi fammi un favore abbassa un pelino
grazie grazie gentile e così è successo
la e morto uno a caso
no ragazzi incredibili sul gioco è come
ho fatto allo scoprirlo prima ti devi
togliere pizza place e va bene che gioco
incredibile e bellissimo
vabbè allora fa mi capire se ci sono le
scorciatoie che fosse eccolo l'ho
trovata la scorciatoia però mi sono
cappottato però c'era scorciato riguarda
aiuto sono quasi primo facendo un giro
veramente strana ma posso tagliare la
mappa c'è la mappa posso tagliare vabbè
allora è facile sono già arrivato
tagliando una cagata tagliando vinci
subito riproviamo senza tagliare a
vedere se riesco arrivare primo senza
tagli di mappa è veramente pazzesca sta
roba
ok se come non devo rallentare mai
perché se non ci metto un botto a
riprendere velocità c'è il gioco
pazzesco è stata la miglior partenza di
un videogioco da quando faccio video
praticamente vi giuro guarda qua ho già
preso una posizione conoscesse viene da
razer comunque questo qua togliti
attenzione ho giocato talmente tanto a
mario kart che sono le tattiche
guarda come la prendo stretta bella sono
primo senza tagliare e ragazze pensione
ottimo la vado a ma ok ciao fatta
fortissimo comunque ragazzi io mi
stupisco ogni giorno di più di quanto lo
sviluppo videoludico vado avanti perché
comunque noi andiamo avanti siamo nel
2020 ma comunque videogiochi si evolvono
volate che passi avanti abbiamo fatto da
gta che poi la vittoria di fianco alla
partenza praticamente c'è quale la
partenza è questa la vittoria tu
tagliando arrivi subito
vabbè a caso la guardi di fare un metro
devi fare un metro perfetto per me
guarda questo è già tutto quello che
poteva avere
va bene abbiamo totalmente quale ora
meno schermo intero altro gameplay
non so se avete presente la di hd poi
c'è l'altra hd che la definizione hd
ultra dh dina hanno fatto questo gioco
di parole è l'incredibile va bene
iniziamo con l'ultra adhd e vediamo c'è
uno che fu ma questo è quando mi sveglio
la mattina e non mick non so dove sono
ancora ecco questo mi succede pronto a
devo mettere il mio nome
fabrizio fabrizio socks fabrizio a
franklin partito di fonda per il mio
nome è fabrizio che c'è qualche problema
che suona e gira nel mondo
salve peggio ancora che devono fare qua
c'è un morto si è sparato ce n'è un
altro e tu suoni
questa è la fine va bene e tu cos'è che
vuoi soldato falt l'entrata nella
problema forse strettamente previta per
il numero di zombie nell'area ma aspetta
mi sembri familiare farmi controllare
qua sembra che ti chiami fabrizio vero
comunque ti farò passare perché mi
fabrizio va bene basta parlare basta
autore di parla di dialogo
entriamo nella foresta anche se va
niente notato che arma è questa se non
fiammifero ma che devo fare fuori di
zombie non vedo l'ora
shift touran madre natura va bene madre
natura vuol dire fater vende ma dall
aspetto che controllo per curiosità che
magari fatto una gaffe incredibile non
vuol dire patria ma non lo so che fare
chiamano fatherland e marcelo siano
faccio gambe
salve lei uno zombie persona suicida ma
come 44 contento tra quanto contento
oggi giorno dopo ha bisogno pezzente era
perfetto non so anche che armati a
questa prova
chissenefrega di belgio questo è il
gioco più bello
dell'altro fase incontro nasciamo
perfetto questo cos'è
ho preso dei bus bruxelles vabbè mira
fuoco reload altra cosa va bene mira
fuoco reload mila fuoco reload ci sono
mira a fuoco reload però non ho nemici o
solo gente è impiccata felicemente non
ci voglio rileggere mira fuoco di love è
ma c'è una gita per fa cagare star ma
[Musica]
vabbè è sicuramente meglio di quella di
prima buongiorno madonna dove voi a
milano in corsa rosa o cacchio o finiti
i colpi aiuto all'amico mesi carica ma
penso che i colpi non siano infiniti a
questo punto maledizione non so come si
aiuto come si carica di me lo dice che a
ok perfetto non ho amo quindi questo
gioco non son riusciti a fare nelle
grafiche decenti perché va beh mi sembra
proprio il compenso sono riusciti a
mettere i proiettili va bene lei
fabrizio può venir a ecco vi aderì far
fuori giovi prima di venire ok faccio io
allenatore padre natura sono lì a novi
sad parte ai patrio e padre on
raga c'è la nebbia se silent hill ce n'è
uno qua faccio fuori questo arrivo
finisco la peperonata e scenicamente a
tanto sono mi hanno fatto malissimo
quindi dovrei recuperare vince
teoricamente contratto colpi evolveranno
carica quindi si ricarica a posto
ragazzi ho un proiettile voi che siete
che dirigente fate le cose wonder for
your right
chissenefrega fabrizio di cago perché
tanto sono state due ora parla della
stessa cosa non c'è un soldato che bello
basta ok diamanti 2 ottobre corte
suprema corte snom one
la corte adesso in sessione per il trial
di fabrizio l'accusa è pronta a vostro
onore cosa lo sviluppatore era è
l'accusa si rappresenta da solo si
chicca che sta succedendo negative di
ragazzi questo era che questi erano due
giochi molto singolari spero che vi sia
piaciuto ricordatevi sempre che questa
musica non sia copyright ata perché sono
ci chiama prossimo episodio iscrivere
chiara restia del tasto mi piace è bella
ragazzi
[Musica]